ó ó
votaram todos devo dizer que na minha
paróquia quando digo votar no início da
missa toda a gente com mais entusiasmo
votar no doutor voltar foi muito bem
esse impacto e eu estava consegue não só
10 encontrando-se asmo
depois desta apresentação distrito de
facto inspiradora e desta peça que vimos
aqui também é inspiradora ela estava com
alguns a equipe com sites de pensar em
ver um padrão a seguir não nos permite
responder com esse empresário não
responderam
mas é muito cinismo que eu tenho certeza
que o tornam da minha presença aqui
enquanto palavra porque o autoconceito
corda e aí essa mensagem que quero
transmitir a mensagem enquanto sacerdote
por transmitir todas as pessoas e que
queria transmitir vos também aqui
perceber que há razões para sorrir
e há razões para o crime ocorrido e
pensava nisto e nesta apresentação como
combinaram eu dei comigo a pensar nas
vezes em que na celebração da eucaristia
na missa às pessoas a rir ou sofreram
comigo ou sentia que o sorriso que é
mais que agregava mais do que o rio por
simplesmente mas eu soube que um sorriso
vem do interior então lembrando que o
ano passado quando as crianças da
primeira comunhão fizeram a primeira
comunhão olhei para o rosto dela se de
facto uma melhoria enorme transbordantes
ele para 11 disse olhem se eu tivesse
que os óculos fantásticos que
conseguissem ver o vosso coração tenho
certeza que o vosso coração tinha se uns
maiô rasgado enorme enorme enorme porque
no fundo é a expressão daquele que
estavam sentindo que o momento do
encontro com ao transcendente que tinham
cavado receber o respectivo também
outras situações e prossegue efusiva
tento nos testes da missa
quantas vezes é que parece para esta
palavra alegria e por essa imensa às
vezes e teve 80 inclusive daquelas
músicas que concorda nem sempre são
muito animadas
é possível mas às vezes a palavra
alegria porque ela só tem tem peso para
nós significa
para nós para os clientes lembremos pois
também de uma outra situação que
aconteceu já uns anos estava eu na missa
com crianças alunos - da primeira
comunhão de desculpa no primeiro ano à
frente e o evangelho era citada aquelas
que são todos nós conhecemos uns 12 ou
13 he meu nome eu estarei no meu deus eu
vou usar uma linguagem que não é própria
para mim o sobretudo se ele souber pode
ficar em maus lençóis mas eu vou citar
aqui uma criança disse
então eu disse muitas crianças vocês
viram esta frase um dois ou três
estiverem reunidos em meu nome é
estranho meu deus só uma vez ouviram
esta esta esta frase em que respondeu
entretanto bernardo tem nada do primeiro
ano da catequese ouvido no ar e isso não
conhece não pensamos nisso outra
assembléia nada
é também isso como mesmo português de um
ou dois ou três
é claro que imagino minha reação a uma
ligação da mãe estava dois anos atrás
fez todas as coisas e mais algumas em
pane completamente a internet sempre que
queria fazer e eu também
minha primeira reação foi a rosa uma
enorme gargalhada e depois tentar compor
as coisas por lei e desconforto muita
gente por aquela reação naquela criança
e por não saber se havia um terrorista
de chorar subiam 0 instalou miúdo o que
queríamos fazer mas olhando agora para
aquela situação nos fez o 2 1 e agora
também é preciso de facto essa postura
de quem está com deus e que está com
deus só pode rir não pode ficar triste
porque porque todos os factos foram as
criaturas somos criaturas do criador e
esta imagem todos nós conhecemos
temos um objetivo na vida um objetivo
uma vocação chamemos lhe assim neste
contexto fé uma vocação seja alguma
coisa para o qual fomos criados e expor
o qual fomos criados não é mais do que
isto a felicidade
quem é que não quer ser feliz isso é que
é ser feliz
assim é fácil e esse é o nosso estilo é
parte fomos criados para a equipe que
deus quer que nós fizemos é sermos
felizes
esta foi a cidade que nós na igreja
podemos chamar toda forma como
claro ou seja aqui é o que é que é santo
entendeu que descobre que viu se chama
terminava um determinado destino a uma
determinada função o treinador já teve
vida que é a felicidade e que deus os
chama vivendo de uma determinada forma
esse é o santo é que ele segue sua
ficção e quem é santo aleixo em flins
sorri
portanto o santos tem que surgir há uma
frase de são francisco es ao santo e ao
jovem conhecido um santo triste é um
triste santo dizer que não concordo com
esta parcela é não concordar com o
sangue é desculpa peço ao senhor mas um
centrista centrista não concorda por que
um santo ou heffley espirre ou então não
é sangue não é santo
nós temos aqui um sorriso que nos
contagiam nós não temos o sorriso do
papa francisco nos contagia e contagiou
o mundo inteiro nos últimos tempos e eu
sinto não 61 mesma desculpa eu vou falar
com cristã mas também como gostaria que
aumentassem ampliassem a minha análise
para todos os cremes
mas eu penso que o papa francisco vai
trazer uma lufada de ar fresco não só a
igreja mas também a humanidade porque
exatamente por isso expressa a
capacidade de ter uma responsabilidade
tão grande em cima de si mas mandar sisu
dom mas anda feliz alegre e uma alegria
que nós percebemos que é uma alegria vem
de dentro vem do interior das convicções
fortes um sentido para a vida
independentemente das enormes
dificuldades certeza pelas quais eu
passo para conduzir a igreja que o faz
sempre com esse sorriso e temos aqui o
teu sorriso irmã cristina todos nós
pelas redes sociais
tivemos conhecimento e sorrir
transbordante e ela apresenta lincoln e
razão do seu sorriso e encontrei uma
frase que acho que é muito curiosa e
tenha certeza que vocês esta santa
teresa de ávila é que vocês já dizia
exatamente a mesma coisa tem mais medo
de uma irmã em feliz de que uma multidão
espíritos maléficos
significa que de facto que uma irmã de
chegar ao convento influentes triste
fato seria uma coisa horrível mesmo o
pior que se pode imaginar do pior dos
espíritos maléficos anos possamos
imaginar eu posso dizer muito
rapidamente que uma das províncias
depois irá contar como surgiu isso que
eu tenho tido nos outros temos é com
vidros talvez tirando a oportunidade com
visitar num convento das irmãs clausura
mas vive em um convento não tem porta
chaves das portas abertas para entrar e
sair quando precisarem mas que
transborda do seu sorriso uma alegria de
felicidade extraordinária com vidros em
montreal temos por exemplo uma qualidade
fantástica que podemos podemos visitar
tem é que estes três sorriso
o sorriso da inesco direito da inês
praia talvez algumas pessoas conheçam o
valentim e provavelmente não conhecem
isto é em angola onde é nossa diocese
está em uma missão e estas duas jovens
têm este sorriso porque tem no peito
três coisas fantásticas extraordinárias
têm no país três coisas tem um coração
enorme
tenha em um crucifixo e tem o valentim e
fala se de facto ferreira por cento em
que está em bruxelas três coisas no seu
pai tom e tem razões para se sentirem
que estão a fazer a sua vocação é
cumprir com o teu projecto deus pra elas
que estou imensamente feliz porque o seu
coração enorme
está a ser oferecido com toda a
generosidade sem esperar nada em troca
este boletim foi um miúdo que está
vestido com uma manga camisola que foi
trazido por estas missionários em mexer
e da américa
ninguém neste praia é fisioterapeuta foi
trazido completamente subnutrido muito
maltratado muito mal cuidado e ter o
nome exatamente valentim a valentim
porque é um valente e conseguiu
sobreviver a todas essas coisas eu
gostaria do do solado forma muito rápida
sobre esta corrente da psicologia que
em voga hoje que só foi proposta por
martin seligman e no fundo procura
potenciar as asas nos dispositivos ou é
perspectiva positiva das pessoas e da
vida
para tornar as para ajudar as pessoas a
viverem verdadeiramente felizes eu falo
em três tipos vidas felizes vida feliz a
partir do brasileiro vida feliz como
comprometida com o compromisso da
família no amor na amizade do trabalho
temos livros seja o que for e uma vida
significativa de uma vida com
significado e tornar sua feliz porque
encontra significava na sua vida
eu queria agora fizemos um exercício
todos já ouvimos falar no senhor jesus
cristo 2 mil anos
enfim todos nós sabemos mais ou menos o
que o fez ao longo da sua vida e vamos
ver aqui algumas propostas dos
princípios alguns dos princípios da
psicologia positiva e vamos pensar seus
cristo não se integraria foi também o
tenente princípios sabedoria e
conhecimento mentalidade aberta espírito
criativo espírito criativo gratuito
criativo capaz de ser considerado
coragem força emocional paixão pelas
coisas pra segurança uma ligada à
capacidade de amar e ser amado simpatia
justiça da cidade lembrança era um líder
sentido justiça declinava duração também
capaz de perdoar humildade por vence e
autocontrole transcendência o homem faz
sentido religioso evidentemente
capacidade de ver para onde esse mesmo
de se maravilhar com as coisas com o
mundo por realizava e ser otimista
nós encontramos as características da
psicologia positiva claramente jesus
cristo jesus cristo foi o primeiro
seguiu a incendiar os anos eu também mas
pelo menos eu cils não consigo ir a
muitos nós também seguem apresentou esta
atitude positiva mas o crente para além
destas precisa de cerca de positiva nos
faz seguir jesus cristo e perceber que
não tem uma proposta que o seu
comportamento nos podem ajudar a ser
mais felizes
o crente é que além disso não conta com
um conjunto mais valias
há uma força que move o cliente não vai
só alguma coisa que o móvel e da força
que já entrou
a asmo tem os horizontes mais largos
não fique apenas circunscrito uma manhã
se iniciará a transcendência centros
sempre amado nunca nunca senta sem amor
sem ser amado por ninguém por zona e tem
um grupo de referência e além disso tem
sempre alguma coisa mais procurado e
essa imagem para alcançar procurado
inclusivamente depois da morte o crédito
tanto não tem motivos para não sorrir
sorrir é sinal de saúde espiritual que
não faltam aos clientes experiências de
alegria e vovós e vovôs mostrar aqui
conheci a alegria pode usar qualquer
plano lançado já consegue quando era
pequenininha porque os meus pais
obrigados a pista obrigou mas digo uma
coisa é uma experiência bem como padre
muito conflitantes
quando alguém se lembra de mim pra pedir
o perdão de deus e eu digo vai em baixo
vai tranquilo porque deus te abraçou e
posou os seus pecados
é uma experiência de uma gratificação
enorme enorme enorme quando essa pessoa
não toca nas mãos eles o gato para por
15 mais por isso
esta experiência e simplicidade que a fé
nos faz sentir bem pode ser que demore
desta imagem
mas podemos dizer também uma coisa que
eu sinto que quando estou na algumas
operação em fim da partida de alguém
ainda o ente querido sinto que essa
operação é um momento de virada porque é
um momento de encontro com uma resposta
que fora do contexto da fé não existe
o difícil mesmo conseguimos encontrar
podemos perguntar sentido de humor
alegria e riso nas coisas de deus não
sair
é estranho pra muita gente estranha e
continuar a ser tratado com muita gente
eu digo que nas minhas orações propor
que isso aconteça porque a asa estimou
esta alegria o riso porque não têm
capacidade do irã
quem não tem capacidade de rir das
coisas de deus não tem não sente a
felicidade ea alegria da fé o amor é o
produto da fé e do riso o início da
oração é uma experiência de oração
interessante quando nós
desafios aqueles que tac porém queremos
fazer uma experiência na oração ou fazer
em oração imaginemos que vão brincar com
os usos o brincar com deus ele está a
brincar com você o que estão sentados e
sentem injustamente vocês a sorrir pra
vocês é uma experiência de oração de
comunhão com deus fantástico mas é uma
experiência que também nós fazemos não
apenas no campo da exploração mas sempre
podemos sempre rimos nós estamos a
responder a deus com os reis sempre
porque deus quer a nossa presidenta
também é reflexo da absoluta
imaginemos cristo rei está a imagem de
cristo do riso se vier a espanha e
queria terminar com esta
com esta frase que é muito forte
pensei nos podem ajudar a sentir aquele
que se pretende que seja a resposta do
40 dentro da vida e nas costas e nas
costas de 60 resposta da sociedade
não te preocupes quando a dificuldade se
atravessa no caminho vi na cara e não te
esqueças está nas mãos de deus
ó ó